the Giants are here and Shanks might be
too as we get one of the most brutal and
jaw-dropping chapters of the egad island
arc so far and wow I mean it is insane
the sheer power on display by these
Giants as they wipe out entire sections
of the massive Marine Fleet in a
stunning show of force and you can say
all you want that these are just fod
Marine ships in the first place but I do
not care it is still just so incredible
to see such powerful allies pulling up
to help the straw hats in this scenario
and while we sadly still don't get to
see Shanks in the chapter I still don't
want to entirely rule out the real
possibility of the red-haired Emperor
actually being here as well because
there are actually a number of reasons
that it really makes sense for him to
arrive at the future Island here too for
one we last Saw Shanks in chapter 179
when he just completely demolished the
entire kid pirate in one slash of his
sords and with that act of just Rome
violence we have entered a new era of
Shanks because no longer is he just
sitting around and waiting for things to
happen nope he is ready to claim the one
piece himself and so it would make a lot
of sense I think if he would actively be
collecting Pony glyphs at this point and
we already saw him take the copies that
kit hat and we do think that he got the
final one from elb possibly at least so
if he truly is on a real Rampage towards
love tale then the next easiest step
would be to come to egad Island and well
steal the one missing Road poneglyph
copy he's missing from the straw hats so
yeah I guess uh evil shank's theory is
still very much on the table or if he's
not here for the poneglyphs well there
is another situation that just makes way
too much sense here because remember
that even if you have the poneglyphs you
still need someone to actually the
cipher and rate them and what a CO
kadink the one person who can do just
that is Nico Robin who is on echad
island and very conveniently right now
seems to be injured and unable to
protect herself so you know just saying
we've been waiting for the Blackbeard
Pirates to swoop in and kidnap Robin all
along but it might just be another
Emperor altogether doing just that in
their stats and if that wasn't enough
yet to satisfy your shank's fantasy I
mean it definitely wasn't for me then
also do remember that Shanks has history
with the celestial dragons and
specifically the GTO in fact at this
point it's very very very likely that he
was basically born a Celestial Dragon
and we've even seen him having a secret
conversation with the five Elders as
well and so wouldn't it just make way
too much sense for the first time that
we actually get to see aot's true powers
that we also learn more about their
connection to Shank of course Shanks
could also Clash here with the
Blackbeard Pirates or the holy Knights
even if either of them actually end up
showing up during this conflict but
either way don't rule out the option
that Shanks is going to show up here
quite yet even if we didn't yet see him
in this chapter which of course we can
say for the people working with him
because back to the Giants since we do
know that they are here for a fact right
now and it's time to take a real uh Deep
dive into what this actually means for
the current Arc and the future of elb
and first of all let's break down why
they are here in the first place in case
some of you are confused well of course
remember that in chapter
1066 we learned that Vega Punk actually
studied all of the research from the
library of Ohara that was rescued and
then moved to elb and of course Vega
Punk seemed to study with the Survivor
of Ohara who is the giant Jaguar the
salt so it would make real sends that
Saul would want to rescue Vega Punk
right now if he actually knew that his
friend was in real danger here in other
words since the Giants are here we could
be seeing Saul very soon in the story if
that were the case however we also see
in this chapter that the two main Giants
Dory and brogie proudly state that they
are here for straw Hat Luffy so maybe it
wasn't Saul who sent the Giants after
all and if that's the case then you do
need to keep in mind that this guy is a
member of the straw head Grand Fleet and
has a portion of Luffy's raver card as
well in other words it is entirely
possible that after Dory and brogi
obliterated the kid pirate ship they
then decided to come find Luffy on their
own maybe they did see that Luffy was in
trouble based on his Beaver cards but
regardless of the reason the fact is
they are here and they have already done
massive damage by erasing the Marine
ships surrounding one part of the entire
Islands which you know leaves a very uh
interesting question on the table here
which is what are they going to do next
well the easy answer is of course to
create an Escape Route for the straw
hats to flee the island I mean remember
that in the last chapter it was once
again explained how the straw Hat's
original plan to use the VAP Force to
get past the blate is no longer an
option at this point which
coincidentally means that the giant
showing up right now does create a very
very much needed diversion for the crws
who will eventually actually escape on
the Thousand Sunny however if you think
that the Giants are just going to walk
up and you know take out Saturn straight
away and kizaru well I think then you're
probably mistaken here so if that's you
take a deep breath of copium right
now because as impressive as all the
damage looks in this chapter we still
have to remember that a 5-year-old big
mom fairly easily took out one of these
Elder Giants who used to be the leaders
of the giant Pirates which means that in
reality despite being the strongest
Warriors in the world these guys
probably shouldn't really be even close
to yonko level which would be the
minimum required power level in order to
actually fight someone like kizaru or
even Saturn now that of course doesn't
mean that DOI and bragi here can't hold
off the world government Fighters at all
though I mean just don't expect this to
be a sweeping Victory now that the
Giants have come to help l at least
that's what we think they're here for I
guess and while we're talking about
their arrival here did anyone else see
Dory call Luffy the sun Gods like excuse
me because honestly that was maybe the
most shocking thing to me about the
entire chapter because as far as we know
no one has told the Giants that Luffy is
Sun God NAA so does that mean that the
Sun God is already part of the Giants
Legends as well and if so does that mean
that they actually also have ties to the
buccaneer race which practically
confirms which we've all assumed all
along that the Giants were also ones
allies of the ancient Kingdom and joy
boy wow I mean I'm just so excited that
the pieces here are finally connecting a
little bit and if the Giants do know
lore about Joy boy then we could be just
learning some of the very exciting stuff
surrounding joy booy and sod Nika very
soon on top of that the Giants of course
knowing about the Sun God and possibly
Joy boy just adds another one piece race
that is once again connected to either
of these two figures as a quick recap
here we already not that the fishermen
made some sort of promise with joy boy
the Mings live on zunisha who stated
herself that Joey Boy has actually
returned and NAA is said to be a hero
for oppressed and enslaved people so all
that put together just makes it all the
more likely that all the races of the
world will Unite with with Luffy to
finally liberate everyone or you know
it's also entirely possible that Shanks
just told the Giants about Luffy's new
legendary status as well but I'm not too
sure why he would even do that at this
point it's a possibility and I guess we
have to consider that as well now to
reel things a little bit back in here I
want to clarify that at this point I
actually do think that an escape is
still more likely for the straw hats
than straight up defeating Saturn and
kizu at this point but if that is
actually true then they will very likely
travel with the Giants for at least a
little while however as excited as we
are for the Giants arrival it could have
soul crushing consequences for the
future of the story here because
remember we have been explicitly told by
Oda that he's trying to condense the
story from here on out and get to the
end and if the Giants are showing up
here when no one really expected them to
then I could easily imagine a scenario
where this is the only interactions we
actually do have with the Giants of
albath because listen to this listen to
this apart from the thrill of Adventure
what actually do we expect from elb an
USA moment most likely finding the
fourth Road poneglyph a reunion between
Robin and Saul I guess but you see like
with the Giants arriving here on ekad
now we could actually get all of those
things once the crew finally escapes
from egad Island which would mean that
there would not even be a real need to
go to elb and I'm not saying that that
is what I want just the opposite of
course but it is a distinct possibility
now that the Giants have actually
arrived here nonetheless if I had to bet
money I'd still say that we're going to
elb and so you know let's assume that
Oda isn't a monster and doesn't give us
El bath and instead once the battle is
over well the straw hats would very
likely actually sail to albath with an
escort of giant longships and the
question of what happens next would once
again be the most important one to
discuss here does Luffy's alliance with
the giant Pirates mean that he's allied
with all the Giants or would the rulers
of elb think a little bit differently
here and of course how does Shanks
himself fit into all of this because if
he isn't here on egad I really hope he
is will the straw hats still meet him on
albath or will he just once again be off
avoiding Luffy collecting the other one
or two poneglyph copies that he still
needs I mean as always it's really hard
to say at this point but there is one
figure connected to the Giants that we
haven't really discussed yet and that is
of course Usopp because if you've paid
any attention to one pie whatsoever well
then you will know for a fact that Usopp
has been connected with the Giants of
ALB basically forever and he has even
befriended many many Giants throughout
the story however he has also literally
done nothing and I mean nothing for the
entire egad Arc so far so if there was
an usub moment that Oda has been saving
for us then well the best time for that
has come right now that the Giants have
actually arrived and that of course
might mean that he has some truly heroic
moments or he gives a very inspiring
speech but either way don't be surprised
if Uso actually shows us something truly
special towards the final chapters of
eket but as hype as the Giants and
potentially Shanks arriving on egad is
though there was also so much more in
this chapter that actually happened
because bodies were dropping left and
right Vega Punk got stabed by Saturn
Frankie and Sanji got blasted by kizaru
then suddenly Luffy returned and slammed
kizaru away from his friends I mean
really this battle is truly heating up
and it does seem like Luffy will end up
holding of kizaru while the rest of the
crew tries to escape but of course
that's still does leave us with Saturn
who is still a very major problem let's
not K around here however we might have
actually figured out how to defeat
Saturn because as we all expected the
piif fistas big surprise are once again
on our side and I mean sure we didn't
know exactly how that would happen in
the end but I don't know who is actually
surprised by this twist at this point in
fact in this chapter Vega Punk actually
revealed that he originally programmed
Bonnie as the highest level of command
for the piif fistas above the goo and so
basically she can order them now to do
whatever she wants which as a result of
course also completely overwrites
Saturn's commands here which obviously
the first thing she absolutely should do
is order them to blast Saturn over and
over again until he is very very dead
and if you remember one of the ways that
we thought you might actually be able to
kill Saturn is to basically keep hurting
him until he kind of runs out of healing
powers and an Unstoppable wave of
overpowered lasers like that seems like
a pretty good wave for me to do that I
think which could ultimately potentially
lead to Saturn's death during this Arc
which would be so so sweet at this point
after everything that he's done or if he
isn't dead then he could also somehow
teleport still to protect himself in
fact I could very much imagine him doing
something very similar to the way that
he arrived on the island in the first
place with this dark mag magic circle
although we don't know exactly still how
any of that really works so who knows if
he could even do that if he wanted to
one way the other though it does leave
us with a few very interesting questions
for the future here though such as will
Bonnie be able to control the Posas just
forever from now on and if so that's
just an insane major boost to her powers
because these things are so so hard to
kill and if Vega Punk made Bonnie the
ultimate Authority for the posy fista
does that mean that he did the same for
the saaim as well now that one I do kind
of doubt since the reason he gave her
command over the piif fista was that he
didn't want Bonnie to be hurt by
something that well looks like her
father is her father who knows but I
mean it's still a possibility he did the
same for the sfim as well though why
didn't viap Punk just reveal this a lot
earlier in the arc and then save
everyone the trouble of fighting the
posy FEA in the first place I mean
storytelling I don't know I don't know I
really don't know that would have been
smart I guess but speaking on Bonnie's
Powers here actually this chapter also
showed Bonnie learning the fact that
Luffy is the real deal the real sunot
NAA now remember that just a few
chapters ago we were shown that Bonnie's
powers are basically fueled by what she
believes is actually possible and so
when she was basically about to be
killed by Saturn she lost faith which
basically drained her entire Powers but
now that she's actually seen Luffy
though I kind of do wonder if if her
powers will actually be restored at this
point or I mean even increased because
of her renewed full faith in the sun
gods and if that's the case what kind of
amazing things do you think could she
actually do with her powers for example
could she make a future where her father
is still alive I mean I'm honestly not
sure at this point but basically
anything certainly seems very possible
really as coincidentally also does
Bunny's chance here to become the next
straw hat and I do know that this has
been discussed by me and others many
many times during the ekad island AR but
this kind of moment with Bonnie that we
saw on the Epic double page spread here
is exactly the type that you know makes
me think that a person could be a
candidate for the straw hats and it
honestly just reminds me of nami's
moment in arlong park or robins and in
this Lobby and to take this even further
we now even have more evidence that she
fits the normal Straw Hat criteria
pretty much perfect L because for one
Bonnie already has a really dark
backstory second she is clearly being
freed by Luffy and is going through her
very own character Journey during this
very Arc and finally if she does end up
traveling with the straw hats well she
has a dream of finding out more about
her father's Buccaneer culture and
belief so bam there you have it
literally the perfect stride candidate
and since she is still technically a
child she could basically be the cabin
girl that nice NE Tama nor mosa ever got
to be or I mean if we want to really you
know lean heavy into that religious
aspect here she could be the ship's
priest or something along those lines
you know like going with Kuma's theme
there but besides that really there is
one other thing that is pretty easy to
miss in all of this chaos and all the
battles happening on the island and
that's of course the fact that we also
got the very first hint of movement from
The Iron Giant here ever since we first
saw an Awakening during chapter
192 which you know it kind of seems like
Oda is really hammering in the idea that
the giant responds to Luffy using gear
five and I mean that is also what caused
it to wake up during the prior chapters
and now that Luffy is back to fighting
with gear five well the Iron Giant has
started moving again and so I'm still
very very excited to see what's going to
happen next with this piece of ancient
technology which again also kind of
implies that 200 years ago when it first
climbed the red line well someone must
have had Luffy's devil fruit and awaken
it too to be able to move it I think
also can we just appreciate a moment
Luffy just casually turning the ground
into rubber to catch his falling friends
like that was a power that we thought
might be his true and only Awakening
power so to see it used as just a small
part of his actual Awakening is pretty
awesome if you ask me at least and if
you're like me and sometimes actually
forget that Luffy's gear five powers are
a lot more than just cartoon wacky
abilities that there is like a whole
thing behind them that can basically
alter and create reality well check out
this video right here where I truly
fully explain all of Luffy's insane
Awakening abilities as far as we
understand them so far and hopefully
that gives you a better overview over
how it works as well if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to like share
subscribe I know it's annoying but it
really does help out the channel
otherwise Shanks so much for watching
and I will see you in the next one